hola que tal muy buenas noches ángel as
pues si efectivamente no se sabe
muchísimos más detalles acerca de esta
operación por parte de la fed y hace
aproximadamente dos horas y media que
teníamos conocimiento de estas
operaciones por parte de las autoridades
de eeuu cuando el propio expresidente
donald trump ha publicado ese comunicado
este extenso comunicado en el que
afirmaba que se estaban llevando a cabo
un allanamiento en mar a lago su
residencia oficial que se encuentra aquí
en el estado de florida consideraba que
esas operaciones eran innecesarias e
inapropiadas y considera que no se
deberían estar llevando a cabo
precisamente el departamento de justicia
de eeuu hasta el momento no ha dado
mayor información sobre es lo que se
estaría investigando en esta operación
que se están llevando aún a cabo en la
residencia oficial del expresidente
donald trump el mismo camps ha dicho que
en los agentes incluso habían allanado
algunas cajas fuertes que
en el interior de la residencia y hay
mucha expectativa por lo que puede pasar
a partir de ahora y razones por las que
se están llevando a cabo estas
operaciones en esta residencia de hecho
y es que hay que recordar que estas
estas operaciones están llevando a cabo
en un momento en el que se está
investigando también qué implicación
podría tener donald trump al asalto al
capitolio que tuvo lugar el 6 de enero
de 2021 y también cuando un jurado
federal tiene que esclarecer si se
cometió o no una violación federal al
encontrar 15 cajas con material
clasificado que en la residencia de mara
lago